pop
[Musique]
lang et le soir on se retrouve
à
[Musique]
c'est
si elle
qui se dévoue
et je te sais
non
j'attends
genre
le seul avec temps
tu vas
tu rentres
mais tout ce qui peut faire
un jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
tu es
je
le sort
on
un soir on se retrouve
je te connais bien et pourtant
chaque pas les yeux des boues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de toujours divers
et
comment venir
tu es
non
ce soir je me jetais
à bord
sauf en
[Musique]
je sors
k
tu m'a plu
histoire
[Musique]
quand viendra la fin de l'été
ils le sont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je chante
un champ
[Musique]
et le sourire
deux temps
visage qu'en bien
la fin
[Applaudissements]
c
j'ai vu
et si le
ses yeux
c'est le drame
[Musique]
sandra
mais quand
quand vient la fin
je
[Applaudissements]
et quand
retrouvez
c'est moi
je ne peux pas
[Musique]
des heureux
déjà
beauregard à la fin
[Applaudissements]
m
bonjour
jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne pourra jamais
[Musique]
tu me
je ne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que je sais que tu dis
c'est un
je ne conçois plus la vie sans toi
ah si monsieur cent de moins en un
triste
c'est parce que tu m'a tendu
[Musique]
moi j'avais perdu mon rythme
m
décidé à me
[Musique]
oui
c'est tout
que
ce pas
c'est
cerrato
si j'ai tellement vu d'hommes
et de ces mots qui parlent de nous
c'est de n'avoir jamais
perso
dans
un jeu tout
[Musique]
je sais pas si
oui
enquête
order
[Musique]
d
c
je
si longtemps
devant
c'est
[Musique]
si je te
c'est tout
je
c'est que
je trouve
m
je me revois mon vieux grand-père à
chicago son histoire
trop tard ils ont aidé au br /
et
mais pas
il me raconte la folie
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
jia
je vous
casino a l'air
luis a
gk
ce rythme
[ __ ] borsalino
j'ai comme
dans ce ballet
gachet
a brigué l'alcool qu'il revend
juge de paix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà pourquoi
oui
alors
à
je vais là
clio garée
allez
à
gk
salut
jega
on y
920 quand il a quitté le pays
ok
à
sans avoir parlé
c'est dans
p
alors je ne va pas
je garde
je vous en place
ok
moi je me
chicago
/
antully pour saler
gk
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
genève
connue
peu de mots
aucun feu de joie à vivre
les compter
et pour
moi j'ai trahi
en quoi mon coeur
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
sourire
oui
[Musique]
mais
à
je
atout chartier
[Musique]
la nuit lorsque même pas
espérée
à trouver un peu
m
que s'y tenait
u2
et pourtant
ma
jeudi
vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde
seul m
plus assez
j'en ai passé deux nuits
marseille
[Musique]
sans savoir
ce que tu écris
il demande
c'est à 20
lui
[Applaudissements]
ma
ce dû
[Musique]
je voulais
[Applaudissements]
une heure
mal
je vois
ce
[Musique]
et
dans
je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est vrai je t'ai seul avocat
et
les jeunes
anton mois
mais peux-tu
en quelque
détruire ma
du cher
regrette déjà coiffe côtés de l'anssi
tu sais comme moi concert
ce sens
si tu t'en
plus rien n'existe
et
pourri
pourquoi faut-il que l'on se fie
je ne peux vivre ça
non
alors
[Musique]
taux
sans toi je
racha que ce vent
[Applaudissements]
c'est un soir de folie
je n'avais pas
non
finissant
mais dis moi je t'en prie
que tu me marre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi faut-il tout le monde sait qui
ils ne
tu sais comme moi
vous saurez
[Musique]
si tu t'en vas
liste
en effet
ils y sont
toi pour tes
ceux ci
je ne peux vivre ce moment
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il
sans toi je me rachat
que ce vent
pourquoi faut-il dénoncer qui
biden
[Musique]
là
le
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez
dans cette vie du
déjà venu en compagnie des familles
tu reconnais
jardin
et les rues
[Musique]
banny
ce fameux palais
tu te souviens
quand vous et dix ans ans
banny pas mis des paniers
une diya
[Musique]
mani mani mani famille
oui
[Musique]
i
le temps fort
oui
tu dedans et par an
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
owona
paris
oui
[Musique]
et
bli joue mal et lui je m'aperçois
gilani
valet
ce voyage commencé comme moi
[Musique]
paris
je voulais savoir
c'est du lait
la compagnie
allez paris
j'ai compris ce soir
[Musique]
le monde
les familles pas de panique
i
ici
[Musique]
non
oui
tu dors en et par an
auj
[Musique]
les
la maison a l'air
les grandes gueules
surtout la chambre ne reste rien de toi
que ton papin je découvre en ton absence
un vide immense
en voyant sourire les roses du jardin
je vis près
sohn sait jamais
deux filles que j'espérais
montrez moi
je sens de
mais si je chante seulement pour me
retenir
mon coeur tu te dis je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
contre qui
et
encore plus
[Musique]
tél
c'est surtout lorsque je rentre que tu
me manques
il faut dire que chaque soir je
m'attendais qui malgré ma solitude par
habitude et encore je t'ai fait chauffer
du café doit perdre un peu la tête
dans la défaite je l'inventé je ne sais
j'en suis
à nouveau les yeux l'éclair
gta lumière
en couleurs sur des poteaux d'une souris
mon coeur pdg
[Musique]
il faut
je
[Musique]
il est
mon coeur dit
[Musique]
achat de voix
mon père dit
[Musique]
il
j'ai trop
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
mon coeur dit
achat
combien
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime à l'italienne
waouh je t'aime à l'italienne
j'ai au fond du coeur une drôle de
chanson sicilienne
que tu sais par quel regard
je t'aime
et forts qu'eux
quand
caen reste
hu
j'étais mal
[Musique]
jala
si sûr
bonjour
digard je chante
ô toi
je ne sais pas
je sais
notre histoire d'amour
me semble hélas
jay reatard ge est pour
tuent les violent
la scala
m
eni romain et moi
mes rêves j'ai fait
en état
derrière
[Musique]
encore là
un mondé
parent
ouais
j'étais mal est fait
je tiens
des lieux
je t'aime
d'ailleurs
j'sais pas
et je
tous
si tu parles
[Musique]
oh
j'étais mort
de taille
gfr
g
et je ne vous
si tu parles
quand le
j'ai su me saoule
si carla
je chante avec lui rien que pour toi
[Musique]